someone always learned it from somebody
else Oh learn the dirty behaviors
you know the M word first time I ever
heard the M word I was at I was in I was
in first grade and these black kids came
in our neighborhood we living in like a
poor white neighborhood and there was a
poor black neighborhood and like across
across across Nebraska Nebraska I forget
well dude that's pretty far then if your
no no no no that was the street name not
the oh right hombre yeah
and so famous dude did not live by black
[Laughter]
then like woo braska and we were florida
and it was scary man it was touch-and-go
at times I'm weird story
oh yeah the rumor mill I saw a note in a
bottle one time in the river
[Laughter]
oh the n-word said it so so these these
black kids lived across this this Main
Street from us and then they came into
our neighborhood I guess and stole my
football my football had a Duke Junior
with a shoelace a tan shoelace as the
strings we just playing the street
mm-hmm and so the string for the
shoelace ripped my dad replaced it with
a little with a with a tan shoelace it
was very distinguishable and a little
part we couldn't tie it so there was a
little like part of the ceiling and hang
out yeah so they came into our
neighborhood and they asked if they
wanted to play this a football and they
had my football hmm and these two
brothers Darrell and Deron like yo they
must I mean I when I remember this story
I'm their feel like they're 18 17
they're probably just like 10 of 11 yeah
and I was six
yeah and they were like you know this is
football and they're like no this is his
football this little other little black
kid and they're like fight him for it
and I was like first grade I was not
fighting anyone I was wearing a
loincloth and knee-high moccasins oh
yeah and so Danny's fighting a sexuality
Bradley pads gonna be sucking dick so so
yes didn't need knee pads to do
what a [ __ ] the good old days support
the Union a backup gay dude yes you mind
if I pull my socks
oh my god
bullocks up I wanted to skin my knees
when I suck your dick do you mind if I
pull my pants down oh if I take my shirt
off in just hey is it cool if I take my
shoes off and put my knees in my
actually if you know some dude that's
not a bad like I would go through all of
those things before you you gotta like
you gotta have some ways to get out of
it you know I've gone down on my wife on
the side of the bed with my knees on the
on the wood floors now that's a grab a
pillow put him on your knees
yeah the but anyway so these black kids
come in the neighborhood and they don't
like fight this kid and I was like I've
never been in a fistfight I want to be
in a fistfight and then Darrell and
Darren looked at me like like oh we
gonna have to do this for you and I was
my head I was like give him the [ __ ]
ball I don't care my daddy bought me a
new one like out like and then they got
no fight big into a fight Darrell fights
one of the dudes or Darren one of them
one of the younger one fights a black
dude and they're all it's like it's like
five black kids and then seven white
kids or eight white cos the more white
kids who's our neighborhood and the dad
comes out and the dad starts tenten
funny fight and we're in a white white
don't win we all jump in and I am
and then he's hitting me it's your ball
[ __ ]
Janet and Here I am just some first
grader in a loincloth in knee-high
moccasins just fine fight and then I
said then I said the word in front of my
dad and it was bucking over really Oh
dad fought him no no no my dad took me
down to their [ __ ] house walk me down
stood in this [ __ ] thing I said don't
ever talk to my son don't I told my dad
I've been in half and they stole my ball
is what he asked me to say so ever talk
to my son and we moved out of that
neighborhood month later month later
when I was growing up you knew not say
the n-word if somebody beats her ass
that's how you knew you know what I'm
saying like that was the litmus it was
like you that's how you learned about it
it was like Oh somebody said it somebody
got their ass beat and then that was it
it's so funny man I never heard it like
I'm not heard it when I was when we
lived in that neighborhood and then I
never heard it in our new neighborhood
never heard it and then I never I never
heard it and I heard it a little bit in
high school but but it was we had a
black friend Corey Brown and all the
kids that grew up with him would drop
the word but as a like not not
derogatory just I was like a joke if if
it was the punt like Anna Louise he get
away but it was the punchline of a joke
meaning towards car Eeyore but it very
light-hearted they were like guys that
he grew up his whole life and then I
heard a lot in college I heard it
[ __ ] well I went to Florida State and
we were segregated it was like FAMU and
Florida State so I heard it a lot
college damn you was more black College
a hundred percent yeah and I used to
drive the black chicks they'd call they
always lived in one dorm it's so funny I
ran into this woman the other day who
went black took my age mm-hmm I went
Florida State and I said hey did you
ever take a safe escort that's what I
was I Drive him around campus and like a
k-card you remember a cake our Papa cake
our can you it was like the [ __ ] the
biggest beater you could ever have yeah
I think it's called a cake or a cue car
it's like old yeah yeah yeah oh yeah
Renault that's uh that's a Renault isn't
it okay that was a that was what it was
white and so and then they would what
would happen is you knew if the black
chicks called on a Saturday night
because you it was just taking people to
the libraries where you supposed to go
okay but if the black chicks call on a
Saturday night you knew they wanted to
go to family you from Florida State okay
and we weren't allowed to drive to FAMU
but once they got in the car you had to
take them wherever they went so what
would happen is they go the
we ever pick up a Dabney Hall one based
one lemon I have a pickup at Deveny Hall
her name's Laquisha and you go okay you
be like is it how many is passengers
like just one that's what they say and
so you'd pull up and then she'd like
wave to you and you go hey and as she
waved they pile on the other side of the
car then they go we're going to fam you
[ __ ] I love it though because I because
I love hip-hop yeah I was just talking
about with him the entire time
everything I learned about wu-tang clan
that way I bought the Method Man album
through them I learned about suave house
MJG and eight-ball it was like ham it
was like the funnest for me because I
loved hip-hop oh yeah so we would just I
would be like what are you guys
listening to and I was driving him for
like [ __ ] 20 minutes so we're
listening to what
there was no player and there was no
player in there sometimes they'd have
and we are wearing seatbelts and
everything Oh there'll be so many people
I was back seat belts were like people
don't even die back then did I see my
kids put on seatbelts I'm like what are
you guys I mean knee pads were blood you
got to put your shoes in your knees and
you're a six where you blow a guy kiddo
you're inserted yeah good evening good
afternoon and other times thanks for
watching that video you just saw I mean
it was okay but the next video you can
watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watch this one